terminé
mais nous ne voulons pas
Ils ont tué ma fille le 21 février,
2018 ils l'ont tuée ils ont détruit son visage
a rompu avec le petit ami mais il va bien
tendu un piège lui a dit que le
invité à un anniversaire et en cela
anniversaire l'a tuée
c'est beaucoup
le ciel
au moment où 10 sont assassinés
femmes quotidiennes dans le pays dans le total
impunité ils nous tuent non pas parce que
soyons pauvres bourses
assez moche c'est une pandémie
projet disney la mission avant vous fait
pour avoir du succès il faut cacher que le
féministe sa mobilité est le langage
manifestation photo personne
[Musique]
ne pas
intello
Merci
mon nom est risque ami et soeur
de valdejasa a assassiné le premier des
février 2019
par le conducteur des transports en commun
où elle voyageait ils nous tuent
ils nous tuent ils nous tuent
partenaire sentimental le voisin haïtien ou le
cousin l'inconnu j'espère vraiment
sortir dans la rue pour revenir
[Musique]
la propriété ne change pas l'examen ne change pas
accepter le sujet pour ne pas avoir
silencieux
la mort de
ma fille vanessa nous a donné un tour sur le
la vie complètement
toute la famille est difficile à vivre
l'absence
d'une fille
c'est dur à vivre
car on s'imagine
si elle a souffert
il a un an
un mois
que ta chambre n'est pas parlée
parce que c'est comme
Si je ne voulais pas qu'elle puisse
c'est comme oui
avoir l'idée qu'elle est là
et c'est que la chambre n'a pas été ouverte je sais
ce n'est pas bien parce que c'est quelque chose qui
nous devons surmonter
mais
nous ne sommes pas préparés
on va dormir et je pense à elle
nous nous réveillons et pensons à elle
nous imaginons qu'il est là dans le
chambre
parfois on a l'impression qu'on perd
la raison
parce que
lis
le parle
et je me suis répondu comme si c'était
elle
je lui ai envoyé des messages
je m'imagine que
comment serait-il en ce moment il aurait obtenu son diplôme
pas le moment où l'on
arrête d'y penser
Je pense qu'au Mexique, on l'a vu dans de nombreux
cas
que tuer une femme n'est pas si
important que comment tuer un homme
Aussi, qu'en est-il des gens?
qui tuent des femmes et jamais
ils auront une punition parce qu'ils penseront
que tuer une femme est si facile et que
rien ne leur arrivera jamais et
les autorités ne leur feront jamais rien
le gouvernement mexicain ne l'a pas dit là
Faisons en sorte que le fémicide ait un
vraiment grosse punition vraiment
forte comme une femme et il faut changer
histoire de défendre nos droits
s'affirmer
donnez-nous la valeur que nous méritons et
Ce que nous avons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je me sens vraiment soutenu et
Je suis aussi triste de voir autant
les gens qui ont été victimes qui m'aiment
la famille a été détruite parce que rien
plus ils les tuent ils nous tuent
tout le monde aime la famille
ré
si la lave s'est déplacée en arrière-plan
avec le chemin de fer qui spécifie le
féminisation la main pro domo condamner
qui veut la même chose qui a gelé les problèmes
au sommet de la politique
et 99 % des crimes
contre les femmes restent impunis
les autorités ne font rien
protéger les femmes est un moment
où nous les femmes sommes seules
abandonné avec un État qui a
a échoué et a fait preuve de dédain et
une paresse sans précédent avec un
claire avec une violation claire de la
lois et traités internationaux et
voir ici aujourd'hui la présence des jeunes
donner le ton qu'ils sont
l'avant-garde montrent avec tout leur
force qu'on en a marre et qu'on n'en a pas
nous ne reculerons devant rien
faire tout ce qu'il faut pour sauver
vie et que si le gouvernement ne comprend pas
un jour on défonce cette porte et
nous allons les forcer à comprendre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maximum
au rallye de foot
projets familiaux
à présent
mais peut-être pas
c'est important
ce ne serait pas bon pour nous
nous sommes des femmes
nous ne voulons pas d'agression nous sommes pour
Encouragez-les
bien à ma mère
follement pour nous
[Musique]
ma mère est ce qu'elle veut
maintenant le regard
la vie
bon
de la place dit
Merci
En fait, il y a des mères avec des enfants de 16 ans.
et il y a 15 ans des filles de 13 ans ici
ici avec leurs mères qui se battent pour leur
droits parce que leurs mères savent
difficile et dans quel [ __ ] ça a été
tout notre pays et ils disent que je ne veux pas
ça pour ma fille je ne veux plus voir
des morts je ne veux plus je ne veux plus
sortir je ne veux pas voir que mon
Soeur soit la prochaine, semble-t-il
sur l'écran quelque chose que vous n'êtes pas
sera celui qui a la merde qui
faut vivre les mamans qui sont
mamans en difficulté toujours à la recherche
leurs propres mères et je ne veux pas ça
pour ma génération
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]